ever heard David Beckham speak it's like
he mouths x2 can of helium ever heard
David Beckham speak it's like he mouths
x2 can of helium I am so sorry
so so so tickets for the cup I can't
wait to not watch Italy play the
Netherlands I can't stay mad at you
Healing hugs here we go Oh God finally
that feels so good
you smell like cinnamon and manhood
we should let those let go of this
burden together just wonderful
no okay whose you're apologizing for
anyway we're just the bit in Deadpool
with the voice doesn't ring a bell
what did you think I was apologizing for
I mean there's a list Green Lantern yup
RIPD or selfless cerebral blade Trinity
politic sorry I know they raised my
voice I lost control
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care additive strong guys
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you missed me read what in
the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you lot smarter
than I look
I meant cable kill this kid but I can't
do this alone
we're gonna form a super-duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender-neutral you will
be known as x-force you're absolutely
right now cue the music
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right
sometimes fight dirty that is why the
man bun is just a millennial mullet oh
god I wish I finished college it lives
up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]